The general way to calculate this is using logarithm.
So you say 2 to the power of N, for example, is smaller than 1 billion,
which means that N must be smaller than the logarithm base 2 of 1 billion,
so N must be smaller than or equal to 29, which is exactly what we're going to put here.
And of course you can do the same calculation for the other ones as well.
So you get here the maximum problem size we can handle would be N equals 217.
Here it's 119, 108, and 51.
The interesting thing to see here I think is that you see how even small changes
in the base of the exponent can make a difference.
So here the change is really small, from 1.21 down to 1.18,
and already we could handle a problem size of 10 more.
And of course this also shows you that the problem size that you can handle,
at least in a worst case scenario, is about 4 times as much as you could handle
if you used a normal search tree.
And of course, if you could find a really, really good search tree--
and there are some problems for which you can come close to 1.1, actually--
then you can handle problem sizes that are almost twice as much as this one over here.
So it's really a significant improvement.
It's not dramatic in the way that now we could solve instance sizes of thousands of vertices
or thousands of variables, but it's a significant improvement.
But it's a significant improvement through using sophisticated algorithms.